لم تهدا بعد تداعيات تغريده الفنانه
اللبنانيه اليسا التي وقعت في مرمى
انتقادات الكثيرين بعد تصريحات حول
اللاجئين في لبنان التغريده التي وصفت
وجود اللاجئين في لبنان بالكارثه اثارت
الكثير من الانتقادات تصل لدرجه وصفها
بالعنصريه فيما كانت الفنانه السوريه
اصاله ابرز الذين ردوا على اليسا ودخلت
على خط الازمه وقالت ان الناس على الارض
زوار مؤكده على ضروره الرحمه بينهم لتعيد
وتؤكد انها لا تقصد انتقاد اليسا وان
صداقتهما لا يمكن ان تتاثر اليسا بدورها
حاول التبرير الكلمات التي كتبتها مؤكده
انها نابعه من حبها لوطنها لبنان وانها لم
تقلل يوما من احترامها لاي شعب وانها
تتمنى للجميع ان يعودوا لاوطانهم بسلام
[موسيقى]